hola que tal buenos dias tal vez la
novedad más fuerte es la que mencionamos
esta es la esquina a mis espaldas donde
se encuentra el edificio donde vive
cristina fernández de kirchner esta es
la esquina donde tuvo lugar ese fallido
intento de homicidio por parte de
fernando sanz mundial en un principio su
novia brenda obligarte había dicho en
declaraciones públicas a medios
argentinos que ella no tenía nada que
ver que no había estado con el derecho
en esos días pero el juzgado reveló y a
través de imágenes también a medios
locales que efectivamente habían estado
juntos ese día se ven imágenes de cómo
están juntos de cómo ella se va en un
momento después de que él hace su
intento de homicidio y también los
medios judiciales fueron revelando a
medios locales información que los
vincula como estando en esta esquina en
días anteriores haciendo lo que algunos
sugieren puede ser algún tipo de tarea
de inteligencia previa a ese intento de
homicidio continúan las investigaciones
y de dos puntos claves uno por supuesto
la motivación porque puede ser que hayan
intentado cometer este intento de
asesinato y también si hay más personas
involucradas y en términos políticos lo
de la motivación es clave porque el
gobierno ha salido decir muy fuertemente
que esto está dado con texto de
discursos de odio que han sido tal vez
el nutriente que ha permitido que ellos
llevaron a cabo este intento de
homicidio desde la oposición se ven
señalados por ese discurso de hoy dicen
que es del otro lado también donde hay
agresión es muy fuerte la realidad que
hay mucha atención en la escena política
argentina uno hubiera esperado y hubo
algunos intentos sigue habiendo de que
haya un acercamiento ahora si puede
haber un consenso para reducir la
polarización algo que por ahora no está
claro y no se ve que esté cambiando aquí
en argentina